la méthode rocard ne fait pas
l'unanimité une partie de l'opposition
hésite encore
m lombard blanchi joël pennel avait
détourné l'héritage de suzanne deux
camps sont elles risquent les assises
référendum sur les réformes économiques
une première dans l'histoire de l'union
soviétique
bonsoir automobilistes attention si vous
voulez vendre votre voiture fait le
rapidement ou payer bien toutes vos
amendes un projet de loi discuté ce
matin en conseil des ministres prévoit
en effet des contrôles renforcés
si le projet est voté on pourra plus
aider sans véhicule sans avoir payé
toutes ces contraventions
hervé dino et christian de carnets ont
mené l enquête désormais pour vendre un
véhicule d'occasion il faudra
impérativement faire amende honorable
les étourdis qui aurait involontairement
bien sûr omid acquitter le paiement de
ces papillons vers qui fleurissent à la
proche des zones de stationnement et des
parcmètres n'auront d'autre ressource
que de regarder leurs voitures rouillées
sur place le projet de loi qui
systématisent la lutte contre les
mauvais payeurs ne devrait pas pourtant
selon les professionnels de l'automobile
avoir des répercussions sur le marché de
l'occasion si le projet n'est pas pour
déplaire aux grands argentiers du
ministère des finances du côté du
ministère des transports on affirme que
cette mesure n'est pas destiné à
renflouer les caisses de l'état
il s'agirait surtout de désengorger les
services de police et les juridictions
qui perdent un temps considérable à
traquer les contrevenants à des lic
paradoxalement la délivrance de ce
certificat de bon payeur qui donnera
lieu à une étude en règle des
antécédents du vendeur risque d'alourdir
la machine administrative
cela nous promet peut-être de beaux
embouteillages dans les services
préfectoraux politique maintenant le
consensus est si difficile à trouver en
ce qui concerne le débat sur
l'immigration qu'une longue nuit de
débat n'a pas suffi les députés se sont
de nouveau sérieusement penchés sur le
problème cet après midi lors des
questions d'actualité et l'après
carpentras semble bien loin daniel
sportiello émotions déception
consternation chez les élus d'opposition
après que le premier ministre l'aurait
déclaré au terme d'une longue nuit à
l'assemblée nationale qu'il ne réclamer
ni leur soutien ni leur aide et que sa
démarche ne visait que l'intérêt
supérieur du pays
prodigue dans l'après midi d'hier est à
voir dans la nuit le premier ministre a
rectifié le tir à 3 heures du matin face
aux réticences de l'opposition
une opposition qui n'a pas manqué de
manifester sa mauvaise humeur
à l'issue de son comité directeur le
parti république a annoncé qu'il n'irait
pas à la table ronde
ce n'est pas une attitude de refus sur
contient une attitude offensive on ne
peut pas c'est pas nous de faire d'être
à la recherche d'un consensus nous le
rpr ne ferme pas complètement la porte
il ne se prononcera qu'après avoir reçu
la lettre promise par le premier
ministre il va nous attendons cette
lettre nous concerterons et en fonction
de ce que verront dans cette lettre nous
irons où nous n'irons pas alors précisé
la meute
la lettre envoyée sous 48 heures aux
formations politiques invitées à
matignon affichera quelques principes
clairs et commun tout le monde suivi de
mesures d'application concrète en
matière d'immigration
le lettre de la dernière chance pour ne
pas rompre le dialogue
même si cet après midi le premier
ministre à conserver un ton ferme et
vous comprendrez qu'en tout état de
cause le gouvernement devra continuer à
agir quelle que soit l'issue la table
ronde à laquelle je vous ai convié la
réponse du premier ministre à ceux qui
lui demandaient si fière de gouverner
quant à savoir si michel rocard trouvera
un consensus politique sur sa politique
d'immigration
la question reste toujours sans réponse
au terme d'un débat fleuve et à huit
jours d'une hypothétique table ronde
jean marie le pen condamné le numéro un
du front national devra verser un franc
de dommages et intérêts à toutes les
associations qui le poursuivait pour la
faire du détail un jugement symbolique
du tribunal de nanterre qui a condamné
jean-marie le pen sur le fond
explications éric thibault c'est la
troisième fois que jean marie le pen est
condamné pour avoir qualifié de point de
détail les chambres à gaz je crois que
c'est un point de détail de l'histoire
de la deuxième guerre mondiale
mais c'est sur le fond cette fois ci que
le tribunal de nanterre vient de
condamner les propos de jean marie le
pen
les juges ont trouvé choquant le choix
des mots un choix qui conduit à la
banalisation des camps de concentration
une victoire symbolique pour les
associations de déportés
ce n'est pas seulement le mot qui est
condamné c'est aussi le ton c'est aussi
les points d'interrogation qui l'avait
mis dans son propos et qu'ils avaient
et permis à tout le monde de comprendre
non seulement le doute qu'il exprimait
mais aussi l'absence de compassion pour
les victimes
ce n'est pas sa doctrine c'est ses excès
personnel et contrôlée de langage
le leader du front national devra verser
le franc symbolique aux onze
associations qui le poursuivaient mais
surtout cette décision du tribunal de
nanterre sera publié dans seize journaux
ce qui devrait coûter 350 mille francs à
jean marie le pen
enfin d'autres actions en justice sont
actuellement en cours contre le
président du front national
l'enquète sur la profanation de
carpentras toujours dans le flou toutes
les personnes interpellées ce matin dans
la région d'albi ont en effet été
relâché en début d'après midi
autre piste celle du groupe islamiste
mohamed bellebou qui bat la
revendication écrite publiée ce matin à
la une du dauphiné libéré ne paraît pas
plus crédible que les deux
revendications téléphonique reçu au
lendemain de la profanation le point sur
les enquêtes claire sébastien mécontent
de n'être pas pris au sérieux le
mystérieux groupe islamiste mohammed el
bour qui m'a envoyé ses aveux écrits au
dauphiné libéré des revendications signé
un arabe les justiciers de l'islam
pourtant cette signature semble enlever
tout crédit à la piste arabe
le paraphe et écrits de gauche à droite
et non l inverse
de plus les lettres formé dans un
alphabet cugy qu'orientale serait d'un
graphisme malhabile fausses pistes ou
provocation l' enquête piétine donc à
carpentras aujourd'hui elles s'étaient
déplacées dans la région d'albi où dès
l'aube un coup de fil et permettait aux
policiers d'interpeller une quinzaine de
jeunes gens parmi eux des skinheads
amateurs de musique dite satanique qui
avaient profané en novembre 88 le
cimetière d'un petit village du tarn
lombaires pourtant entre hard rock et
l'ésotérisme la filière du tarn n'a pas
abouti tous les jeunes gens ont
finalement été relâchés
les skinheads d'albi ne sont pas les
profanateurs de carpentras m lombard
blanchi après avoir risqué la prison
pour recel dans la sphère de la
captation d'héritage de madame deux
camps sont le célèbre avocat a bénéficié
aujourd'hui d'un non-lieu il ne
ce sera donc pas devant le tribunal rien
de tel en revanche pour joël pennel la
principale inculpés qui risquent les
assises le point sur la sphère albert
ripamonti lombard rime avec amateurs
d'art et cette passion pour la peinture
a failli coûter très cher aux ténors du
barreau marseillais en décembre 89 le
juge bernard de toulon où l'inculpé de
recel dans le dossier de caen sont qu
une affaire de captation d'héritage
une vieille dame richissime suzanne de
canson se fait déposséder de sa fortune
par sa dame de compagnie joël pennel
qu'il aurait laissé mourir sans soins un
trésor constitué en fait de toiles de
maîtres des rembrandt fragonard quentin
la tour et un mur rio c'est précisément
ce portrait de gentilhomme sévillans qui
va valoir les pires ennuis à mettre
lombard le juge lui reproche d'avoir
négocié sa vente pour le compte de joël
pesnel
le montant de la transaction 5 millions
de francs 10 mètres lombard beaucoup
plus estiment d'autres aucun doute en
revanche sur la destination des fonds
l'argent a directement filé dans la
poche de joël pesnel aujourd'hui donc
maître paul lombard est totalement
blanchi dans cette affaire
quant à joël pennel elles risquaient les
assises pour séquestration arbitraire
d'une durée supérieure à un mois ce qui
constitue un crime au regard de la loi
l'actualité à l'étranger avec une
décision surprenante en union soviétique
le gouvernement envisage en effet de
soumettre l'introduction des réformes
économiques et un référendum plus
étonnant encore si la population
soviétique repousse ce projet de réforme
le gouvernement pourrait se démettre
alors qu'en est il exactement de cette
réforme
il s'agit à partir du 1er janvier 91
d'une augmentation simultanée des prix
et des salaires
un cap bien difficile à passer pour
mirail leurs bêtes sauf explications
sylvie levey fait exceptionnel
aujourd'hui à moscou un syndicaliste un
réformateur et un conservateur à la même
tribune pour débattre autour de la
nouvelle réforme économique de gordon of
une révolution en douceur dans les
règles du marché soviétique
a contrario de la polonaise mais qui ne
fait pas pour autant l'unanimité alors
l'astuce de gorbatchev pour maintenir
les rênes du jeu
neutralisé en bloc radicaux et
conservateurs un référendum populaire
les détracteurs de la pérestroïka le
milieu des syndicats en tête reprocher
ce matin encore à la future économie de
marché de risquer de mettre en péril les
acquis sociaux de la révolution
d'octobre 17 argumentation des
mécontents d'ici à 1992 le niveau de vie
des gens baisserait de 5 à 6% et le
nombre des chômeurs seraient multipliées
par deux atteignant le chiffre des 4
millions cette annonce de référendum
pour un projet de réforme élaboré de
concert avec les milieux syndicaux et
les divers courants politiques aura au
moins le mérite de faire partager
sciemment aux citoyens soviétiques tout
l'effort d'une révolution dans leurs
moeurs économique
une vraie caution populaire pour le
président du kremlin peut-être son
sursis salvette pour la paix une
information qui vient tout juste de nous
arriver le parlement lituanien propose
la suspension de certaines de ces lois
découlant de la déclaration
d'indépendance étrangers toujours quatre
jours après l'attentât de rishon lezion
la situation dans les territoires
occupés est toujours tendue depuis le
massacre la bande de gaza un territoire
au sud d'israël est sous couvre feu et
la zone a été interdite à la presse
notre équipe a été la première à pouvoir
accompagner une patrouille israélienne
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
clément weill raynal et pierre michel
gaza ville morte depuis quatre jours
cette zone occupée par israël ou vivre
sept cent mille palestiniens est sous
couvre-feu
interdiction pour les habitants de
sortir de chez eux sauf en cas d'urgence
comme ces femmes qui se dirige vers un
hôpital mais tous vos placements est
soumis à autorisation
il est une heure de l'après midi nous
sommes à la limite de gaza et du camp de
réfugiés de chati la ville est déserte
toute activité est interrompue une
journée plutôt calme pour les soldats
aucun incident grave pour le moment
n'est à signaler les yeah yeah deux
palestiniens ont été tués lors
d'affrontements entre l'armée
le bus du couvre-feu selon les autorités
israéliennes
obtenir un retour au calme en évitant au
maximum les incidents après l'attentât
de rishon le zion l'émotion dans la
population et l explique le lieutenant
que si les gens étaient dans la rue il y
aurait sans arrêt des accrochages avec
les soldats alors il vaut mieux sur tout
le monde que les gens restent chez eux
en attendant que la tension auto morts
place de palestine au centre de la ville
c'est l'un des points les plus dures de
l'intifada nous sommes à proximité de la
grande mosquée est ici à gaza ce sont
les intégristes du mouvement hamas qui
conduisent la révolte et non l'ol paie
quelques rares jets de pierres et une
forte odeur de lacrymogènes nous signale
qu'un affrontement vient d'avoir lieu
toute la journée l'administration
israélienne va se renseigner notamment
auprès des notables pour savoir si la
tension est retombée
personne ne sait combien de temps encore
va durer le couvre-feu c'est ce soir que
l'administration israélienne prendra la
décision de lever ou de maintenir le
couvre-feu et bien entendu le retour à
une situation normale et la possibilité
pour les habitants de gaza de sortir de
chez eux ne règle en rien le problème de
l'intifada et puis toujours à ce sujet a
noté un important rassemblement ce soir
place du trocadéro après la tuerie de
rishon lezion venu chez à l'appel
notamment du mrap et de france palestine
les manifestants scandaient nous sommes
tous des palestiniens
au chapitre économique la clio fera
bientôt son entrée sur le marché de
l'automobile française et celle usine de
flins qui a été choisi pour monter la
petite dernière de la firme renault un
souffle nouveau pour l' usine de flins
bien sûr mais concrètement que
représente au niveau social la
construction d'une nouvelle voiture dans
une usine réponse marielle un petit show
clio et la petite dernière de renault
une nouvelle voiture c'est un peu la
révolution dans l' usine un moment clé
pour augmenter la productivité la
qualité réorganisation du travail en
petites équipes
avant donc partielle du taylorisme pour
motiver responsabiliser question de
rentabilité dans les rencontres avec les
prix
formation pour changer les mentalités un
maillon stratégique de la chaîne
les agents de maîtrise un atout la
moitié de la maîtrise n'était pas là il
ya trois ans actuellement il s'agit
davantage pour eux d'animer des équipes
de de faire jouer leurs compétences
techniques ou d'animateur auprès des
opérateurs de servir d'interprète entre
la donc les cadres et puis les
opérateurs bref c'est un rôle beaucoup
plus de communicants et d'animateurs
s'immoler claude un rôle de commandement
sont strictes et traditionnelles
révolution technologique si l'atelier de
montage et automatisée partiellement la
tôlerie les à 99% révolution dans
l'organisation du temps de travail c'est
la clio marche
une troisième équipe sera mise en place
sur la base du volontariat l'année
prochaine pour répondre à la demande en
conséquence les équipes de jour
commençons plutôt la troisième équipe
sur le fond je suis pas content mais les
horreurs qui ont été mis en avant pour
ma part
me lever à 3 heures du matin ça me
paraît pas quelque chose de
raisonnablement possible c'est la
production l'église on est tous risques
d'attraper plus de flexibilité pour
faire tourner les machines plus
longtemps professionnalisation pour plus
de qualité
l'enjeu est énorme pour les usines de
flins si le succès est au rendez vous la
création de 1000 emplois est en jeu et
l'on reparle des emprunts russes et leur
parle surtout du remboursement de ses
emprunts 84 parlementaires français ont
en effet demandé au ministre de
l'économie et des finances pierre
bérégovoy de faire pression sur françois
mitterrand avant sa rencontre avec
mikhaïl gorbatchev vendredi prochain les
anglais avaient réussi la performance de
se faire rembourser
reste à savoir si les français
bénéficieront de la même perez troïka
boursière reportage bernard ségara
françois mitterrand osera t-il parler
des fameuses emprunts vendredi à michael
gorbatchev affaire d'état il ne reste à
vrai dire seulement que 250 à 300 milles
porter sur un million et demi en 1919
coquette somme plus de 12 milliards de
francs or à l'époque les parlementaires
français estime dans la lettre qu'ils
ont adressée au président de la
république que l'urss devrait d'abord
commencer par rembourser ses dettes
avant de pouvoir bénéficier de nouveaux
emprunts de la banque européenne que
préside désormais jacques attali c'est
un problème de principe
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas laisser
des dettes impayées par un état sinon ça
veut dire que pour y avoir d'autres
emprunts qui seraient faits et dont les
états considérés qui n'ont pas à être
remboursés
d'après mme deux précédents donc on peut
pas lâcher sur le prince le prime du
précédent et puis il ya eu spoliation de
petits porteurs et c'est resté très
présent dans l'inconscient populaire
français monsieur gorbatchev
acceptera-t-il de rendre de la main
droite une partie des sommes qu'il
encaissera de la main gauche il donnait
ainsi raison à la fable qui paye ses
dettes s'enrichit les universités au
service des urgences pour y remédier le
conseil des ministres a adopté ce matin
le projet université 2000 doté de 23
milliards de francs cette réforme
permettra de faire face à l'arrivée
d'ici quatre ans de 350 mille étudiants
supplémentaires
alors quelles seront les répercussions
sur le terrain enquête dans la région
lilloise signée initial vieux 23
milliards de francs sur cinq ans cela
consiste pratiquement à doubler le
budget consacré à la construction
chaque année l'état français accorde 2 7
milliards soit 10 % du budget de
l'enseignement supérieur et fort
inévitable a lille la cité scientifique
par exemple accueille vingt mille
étudiants dans une structure prévue pour
6500 il faudrait 76 mille mètres carrés
en plus dont l'honneur les responsables
universitaires réclame 15 % du plan
total c'est à dire d 1 million 500 mille
mètres carrés pour être efficace ce plan
devra être suivie d'actions dans
d'autres domaines le personnel de
fonctionnement des locaux les délais de
mise en oeuvre et le développement des
structures pour la recherche un plan
plus prospectif pour les années 95 1
2000 doit suivre ce premier plan
quinquennal 2004 symbole vih-sida
l'université française à défaut d'avoir
pris de la vence aura dû combler son
retard sur la réalité économique et sur
ses voisins européens
tout de suite les autres faits marquants
de l'actualité en france grâce aux
images de nos stations régionales
commentaire laurence piquet
le ton se durcit au quotidien régional
l'union de rentrer hier la direction a
suspendu la parution du journal
motif empêcher la sortie d'un communiqué
syndical en première page communiqué
inséré sans l'accord de la rédaction à
l'origine de ce conflit engagé ya six
semaines
le projet de modernisation de l'union de
rance dont l'associé majoritaire et
philippe hersant
la sortie aujourd'hui du premier
quotidien de france en braille l'est
républicain propose dans un cahier d'une
trentaine de pages
la synthèse de l'actualité nationale et
internationale
une édition distribués sur toute la
france
deux fortes perturbations à nice pour ce
week-end de l'ascension de préavis de
grève ont été lancés à la sncf et à la
tour de contrôle de l'aéroport
international grève de trois jours à
partir de samedi qui risque de bien gêné
les amateurs du grand prix automobile de
monaco dans cette usine désaffectée de
calais près de 800 kg de pyralène
s'étaient échappés de fait plusieurs
semaines le transformateur avait été
visitée miracle il n'y a pas eu
d'incendié
reste à savoir à présent si la nappe
phréatique a été polluée enfin le 28 ème
prix roger nimier attribué à eric
neuhoff pour son roman les hanches de
laëtitia prix attribués au troisième
tour de scrutin à l'unanimité neos
journaliste et écrivain brosse dans son
dernier roman le portrait de trois
jeunes hommes amoureux de la même femme
le théâtre mémoire de l'histoire est
témoin de l'actualité c'est le cas
depuis quelques jours et jusqu'à ce soir
à créteil où se joue la pièce sigma ring
donne une pièce qui retrace les derniers
mois du gouvernement de vichy réfugiés à
la fin de la guerre dans un vieux
château germanique claude lehmann est
allé recueillir les réactions du public
mais aussi des acteurs au regard des
événements de carpentras sigmaringen
écrit et monté par daniel benoin à
saint-etienne a commencé à tourner en
france dès février 90 depuis le choc de
carpentras les spectateurs comme les
interprètes
ressent-il différemment cette pièce sur
la fin minables des hommes de vichy
un drap blanc dit papa car contrat ça
fait peur donc c'est intéressant de voir
des pièces comme ça qui nous rappelle à
notre mémoire quoi c'est comme une
période troublée c'est intéressant
d'exorciser un peu les vieux démons de
cette époque là on n'a rien changé
évidemment à la pièce mais il est
évident que certaines phrases on
prononce dans cette pièce que vous
rappelle que c'est sur la collaboration
et certaines phrases qui sont dites en
particulier contre les juifs reprennent
tout à coup une actualité du service
tient un peu troublant par moments la
raison est dans la merde en être le huis
lanveur au coup de téléphone que je
reçois ou témoignages que j'ai d'amis ou
de spectateurs je me dis que les gens
ont été on était vraiment heurter par
les événements de carpentras et que
maintenant cette pièce a une résonance
qui pour eux est réelle et actuelle
ce spectacle nous rappelle qu'une
certaine forme d'art direct conservé
plus sa fonction dans nos sociétés trop
à venise il avait 71 ans et il incarnait
depuis toujours l'image du gosse sortie
des bas quartiers de manhattan grâce à
la boxe
rocky graziano est mort la nuit dernière
à new york après une carrière étonnante
champion du monde des poids moyens en 47
sa vie avait fait l'objet d'un livre et
plus tard d'un film qui l'avait rendu
très célèbre nostalgie sur le ring
didier balèze rocky graziano de son vrai
nom thomas socoba rebella est décédé à
new york d'une défaillance
cardiopulmonaire à l'âge de 71 ans né à
manhattan son père boxeur lorient très
vite vers le ring il débute sa carrière
à 17 ans son palmarès 67 victoires sur
83 combat il est resté surtout célèbre
pour ses matchs violence est acharnée
face à tony zèle italo américain devient
champion du monde en 47
mais tony zèle ici sous vos yeux lui
reprend la couronne mondiale en 1948 par
ko à la 3e reprise
il prend sa retraite sportive en 52 pour
travailler dans la publicité
rocky graziano resté très populaire on
le verra à plusieurs reprises face aux
caméras aux côtés de martha raillé sa
vie fait l'objet d'un livre puis d'un
film et c'est paul newman qui incarne le
champion n'en sommes maudits haute vers
la x me même si certains ont pu
critiquer ses relations la disparition
de l'ancien champion des moyens à triste
aujourd'hui tous les défenseurs du noble
art à la fin de cette édition les
programmes sur l'a3 ce soir du théâtre
avec à 20h35 avec les chaises d'eugène
ionesco acteurs pierre dux et denise
gence à 21h55 mille bravos suivi de soir
3 à 22h55 présentée par marc hautement
bonsoir à demain
m
tout